el triángulo s m este es el triángulo s
m
se rota 270 grados alrededor del punto 4
- 2 este es el punto 4 menos 2 y dice
traza la imagen de esta rotación
utilizando la gráfica interactiva vamos
a utilizar esta herramienta es una
gráfica interactiva en la que podemos
colocar puntos donde queramos por
ejemplo aquí y si no lo quiero lo puedo
quitar arrastrándolo al bote de basura y
dice ahora la dirección de una rotación
con ángulo positivo es en el sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj
entonces vamos a rotar 270 grados en el
sentido contrario a las manecillas del
reloj y para pensar en ello lo que hice
fue copiar y pegar esta imagen del
ejercicio en esta herramienta de dibujo
aquí ya podemos dibujar ahora en el
vídeo pasado ya había hablado sobre una
rotación alrededor del origen
en la que rotamos menos 270 grados
alrededor del origen pero si estamos
hablando de una rotación de 270 grados
podemos pensar en que si tenemos aquí un
punto si imaginas que tenemos ahí un
punto
esto sería rotar 90 grados
esto sería rotar 180 grados y esto sería
rotar 270 grados
esta es una rotación de 270 grados y es
en sentido contrario a las manecillas
del reloj y ves que eso es equivalente a
una rotación de 90 grados en el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj o lo que es
lo mismo una rotación de menos 90 grados
es más fácil pensar en una rotación de
90 grados entonces en lugar de pensar en
una rotación en términos de 270 grados
en la dirección positiva es decir en la
que va en sentido contrario a las
manecillas del reloj pensemos en una
rotación de 90 grados en el sentido de
las manecillas del reloj es equivalente
pero como hacemos eso bueno como lo he
hecho ya en vídeos previos lo que haré
es tomar cada punto de este triángulo
voy a iniciar en este caso con el punto
m y voy a construir un triángulo
rectángulo entre el punto m y nuestro
centro de rotación entonces la
hipotenusa de nuestro triángulo
rectángulo será precisamente el segmento
que conecta al punto
y el centro de rotación entonces aquí
voy a construir la hipotenusa del
triángulo rectángulo y aquí está un lado
acá está el otro lado ahí ya tenemos
nuestro triángulo rectángulo entonces ya
que tenemos nuestro triángulo rectángulo
ahora imagina rotar este triángulo
rectángulo en un ángulo de menos 90
grados es decir en el sentido que giran
las manecillas del reloj qué va a pasar
con cada uno de los lados de este
triángulo rectángulo una vez que los
rotamos menos 90 grados primero veamos
qué pasará con este lado entonces si yo
roto este lado en un ángulo de menos 90
grados su posición quedará hacia arriba
y cuántas unidades de largo tendrá bueno
vamos a contar
tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
así que 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 entonces su
posición quedará justo así es el lado al
rotar lo menos 90 grados quedará así
ahora veamos este otro lado del
triángulo rectángulo que construye este
que voy a colorear en color verde en
este lado mide cuatro unidades de largo
y aquí se forma un ángulo recto ahora si
rotamos todo el triángulo 90 grados en
el sentido que giran las manecillas del
reloj entonces este lado irá 4 unidades
en esta dirección
ajá y entonces la imagen del triángulo
rectángulo que construir el cual rotem
en los 90 grados se mirará así aquí está
la hipotenusa de ese triángulo entonces
ahí ya quedó el triángulo pero qué fue
lo que hice lo que hice fue tomar este
triángulo tomé este triángulo rectángulo
que construir y lo rote menos 90 grados
para obtener este triángulo para obtener
este triángulo de aquí
y entonces tenemos que el punto m
su imagen del punto m después de la
rotación de menos 90 grados quedará
justo aquí este punto que llamaré m
prima entonces ahora falta hacer lo
mismo pero para el punto a y para el
punto s así que lo haré para el punto ai
para el punto s después voy a conectar
los puntos s prima a prima y m prima
para obtener la imagen del triángulo s a
m después de la rotación hagamos lo
mismo para el punto a entonces voy a
construir un triángulo rectángulo desde
el punto a hasta el punto de rotación y
bueno aquí sabemos que aquí irá la
hipotenusa y puedo construir el
triángulo rectángulo de dos maneras
podría construirlo así y después de
bajar pero lo haré de esta otra forma
bajaré aquí y después el siguiente lado
del triángulo rectángulo sería de aquí
para acá al centro de rotación ahí
tenemos ya un triángulo rectángulo y
este lado si lo rotamos menos 90 grados
en lugar de estar en posición horizontal
estará vertical y va a estar sobre este
lado que ya habíamos dibujado ahora
cuántas unidades de largo
bueno pues podemos podemos contar
entonces estaría estaría 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 unidades de largo así que aquí
empezamos en igual a menos 2 y agregamos
9 va a llegar hasta igual a 7 tenemos
que agregar 22 de igual a 7 hasta aquí
muy bien ahora vamos con el siguiente
lado vamos con este lado que voy a
colorear con verde aquí se forma un
ángulo recto aquí se forma un ángulo
recto entonces acá también se va a
formar un ángulo recto
notemos ese lado menos 90 grados y
cuántas unidades de largo bueno pues hay
que contar entonces este tiene 1 2 3 4 5
unidades de largo entonces va una dos
tres cuatro cinco unidades de largo
hasta aquí llega después de la rotación
y justo ahí está el punto a prima aquí
está el punto a prima después derrotarlo
aquí queda el punto a prima entonces
pongo a prima y ahora ya podemos
completar este triángulo colocando aquí
esto es la hipotenusa del triángulo que
construimos y así se mirará el triángulo
después de haberlo rotado menos 90
grados así que después de la rotación ya
sabemos dónde está la imagen del punto m
y también sabemos dónde está la imagen
del punto a después de la rotación y se
ve claramente cómo estos triángulos que
hemos construido los rotamos 90 grados
en dirección que giran las manecillas
del reloj ahora sólo nos falta hacer
esto para el punto s y ya tendríamos así
los tres puntos para la imagen del
triángulo rotado así que hagamos eso
para ese entonces desde ese voy a
construir la hipotenusa que va hasta el
centro de rotación este sería otro lado
del triángulo y este otro lado ahora
desde este lado si yo lo roto menos 90
grados este lado que voy a colocar en
color naranja al rotar lo menos 90
grados es decir 90 grados en el sentido
que giran las manecillas del reloj esta
horizontal entonces va a quedar
totalmente vertical ajá y mide va desde
menos 3 a 4 así que mide 7 unidades de
largo entonces va a quedar 7 unidades de
largo pero en posición vertical hasta
aquí así que va a quedar así
ahora vamos con este otro lado del
triángulo rectángulo que construimos
este lado que voy a colorear con azul
ahora aquí se forma un ángulo recto como
puedes ver aquí tenemos un ángulo recto
ese ángulo recto yo al rotar este lado
ese ángulo recto se mantiene y como aquí
baja tres unidades entonces al rotarlo
va a estar tres unidades pero a la
izquierda entonces aquí tenemos un
ángulo recto aquí tenemos al punto s
prima que es la imagen del punto s y
aquí tenemos ya entonces la hipotenusa
de este nuevo triángulo que es la imagen
del triángulo anterior ahora todo esto
puede parecer algo muy complejo pero
solo observa que rotamos todo menos 90
grados entonces este triángulo que
construye este triángulo se mapea a este
otro así que este triángulo que yo
construí simplemente al rotar lo menos
90 grados se mapea a este triángulo
después de la rotación de menos 90
grados
pero ahora ya tenemos en nuestra imagen
a los puntos s prima a prima y m prime
entonces podemos conectarlos entonces
los voy a conectar s prima a prima los
conecto a prima m prima y m prima s
prima y tal vez después de todo esto
parezca algo complejo lo que hicimos y
no veas dónde está el triángulo original
que teníamos al inicio era éste
éste era el triángulo original que
teníamos al inicio pero observa que lo
que hice simplemente fue rotar todo
menos 90 grados o lo que es lo mismo 270
grados entonces hacemos la rotación del
triángulo sm para mapear lo en este
nuevo triángulo y así tenemos que la
imagen del triángulo s
m es justo
este triángulo de aquí el triángulo s
prima a prima y m prima ahora que ya
tenemos esto sólo nos falta ingresar los
datos al ejercicio entonces veamos las
coordenadas de los puntos s prima a
prima y m prima entonces 8,5 es la
coordenada del punto m prima esta sería
la imagen del punto m m prima aquí está
ahora el punto a está en 97 entonces
colocó un punto en 97
97 aquí
97 ahora nos falta el punto s prima s
prima está en 15 entonces colocó un
punto en 15
y conecto ahí está el triángulo y listo
rotamos en un ángulo de 270 grados o lo
que es equivalente un ángulo de menos 90
grados